Mick Flannery: I'm going to
make you miserable for awhile.
It's a motivational thing
for lunchtime at Google.
♪ [piano playing]
♪ I can only speak for those
who do not know me,
♪ I can only write the words
that would not show me,
♪ I will never quite explain
what I've been doin'.
♪ I am you and you are me
but we are nothing,
♪ My heart broke and rose to go
but I'm not goin',
♪ Cause I loved you long
before the day I told ya.
♪ And it's you and it's me
and it's time on our side,
♪ Tonight I want you to be my safety rope,
♪ Oh, but tonight you've got a heavy load.
♪ We both shine for morning time
we'd spend together,
♪ We don't pine or cross the line
or go one better,
♪ And we would sing to those
who'd bring us stormy weather.
♪ And it's you and it's me
♪ and it's time on our side,
♪ Tonight I want you to be my safety rope,
♪ Oh, but tonight you've got a heavy load.
♪ And she said that I want my innocence, man,
♪ I want my confidence back,
♪ I don't wanna feel like this no more.
♪ Pull up they push and play,
♪ Now you're this fool they made you,
♪ I don't wanna feel like this no more.
♪ [piano playing]
♪ And it's you and it's me
and it's time on our side,
and it's time on our side.
♪ [piano playing]
[applause]
Mick Flannery: Thank you.
Cheers.
I'm a little bit nervous.
This is a little bit weird.
[laughter]
Slightly -- not too bad,
but a small bit.
You're on your lunchtime?
So you've given up your lunch, then?
Sorry.
This is a Tom Waits song.
♪ [piano playing]
♪ Well, she's up against the register,
♪ an apron and a spatula,
♪ Yesterday's deliveries,
♪ tickets for the bachelors,
♪ She's a moving violation from
her conks down to her shoes,
♪ Well, it's just an invitation to the blues.
♪ But you feel just like Cagney,
♪ she looks like Rita Hayworth,
♪ At the counter of the Schwab's drugstore.
♪ You wonder if she might be single,
♪ she's a loner who likes to mingle,
♪ Got to be patient,
♪ try and pick up a clue.
♪ She said,
"How you gonna like 'em,
♪ medium or scrambled?"
♪ You say "Anyway's the only way",
♪ careful not to gamble,
♪ On a guy with a suitcase and a ticket
getting out of here in a tired bus station
♪ and an old pair of shoes.
♪ It's just an invitation to the blues.
♪ But you can't take your eyes off her,
♪ you get another cup of java,
♪ And it's just the way she pours it for you,
♪ joking with the customers.
♪ Mercy, mercy, Mr. Percy,
♪ there's nothing back in Jersey,
♪ But a broken-down jalopy
of a man I left behind,
♪ And the dream that I was chasing,
♪ a battle with booze,
♪ And an open invitation to the blues.
♪ [piano playing]
♪ She don't have a sugar daddy
and a candy-apple caddy,
♪ A bank account and everything,
♪ accustomed to the finer things,
♪ He probably left her for a socialite,
♪ and he didn't love her,
except at night,
♪ And then he's drunk and never
even told her that he cared.
♪ So they took the registration,
♪ car keys, and his shoes
♪ And left her with an invitation
to the blues.
♪ 'Cause there's a Continental Trailways
leaving local bus tonight, good evening,
♪ You can have my seat,
I'm sticking round here for awhile.
♪ Get me a room at the Squire,
♪ the filling station's hiring,
♪ And I can eat here every night,
♪ what the hell have I got to lose?
♪ Got a crazy sensation, go or stay?
Now I gotta choose,
♪ I accept your invitation to the blues.
♪ [piano playing]
[applause]
Mick Flannery: Thank you.
It's very uplifting stuff, isn't it?
You're going on to take on
the Chinese or something?
Need war music or something.
I don't know about that one.
There's a lot of those guys.
[Laughter]
Taking on the Chinese.
Getting ahead of yourselves. Right.
♪ [piano playing]
♪ I sat here watching the sun slip away,
♪ And all your roses are dead
as the day is now.
♪ Nothing grows in this house.
♪ [piano playing]
♪ And I don't know what I want anymore.
♪ Dry throat as you walk out the door.
♪ I know we can't be seen here tomorrow.
♪ You can't be seen here with me.
♪ I like you,
♪ you like me.
♪ We're over.
♪ You cut it clean.
♪ You shook me up.
♪ You shut me out.
♪ And all the world in the simplest of things,
♪ And if she knew just how
easy that ring comes off,
♪ Off and on.
♪ Woo...
♪ What would I give to be
somebody else?
♪ And don't you wish that
you never met me now?
♪ Or set foot in this house?
♪ The way the shame walks around.
♪ And I like you.
♪ You like me.
♪ We're over.
♪ You cut it clean.
♪ You shook me up,
♪ you shut me out.
♪ La la la, la la la la,
♪ How you got to a weakness in me,
♪ Whenever you want me,
you'll know where I'll be.
♪ [piano playing]
[applause]
Mick Flannery: Thank you.
[guitar strumming]
Mick Flannery: I have the stage presence
of a goat. [laughing]
[guitar strumming]
It doesn't help in my line of work, really.
[tuning guitar]
Sorry.
♪ [guitar playing]
♪ I hit the bottle baby,
♪ I lost some time,
♪ I did it all except get you off my mind.
♪ I gave the act a cleanin',
♪ Dry as a bone,
♪ You beat the shakes, you break,
pick up the phone.
♪ Just to win back my baby's heart,
♪ And to tell her I would never tire,
♪ Let it ride, yet you know it's wrong,
♪ Bein' the love that you know is gone
I'll be the rock that you perish upon.
♪ Then hit the road together,
♪ You walk the line,
♪ You try to make it like the good ol' times,
♪ But soon the fires started,
♪ Went out of phase,
♪ I didn't wanna but you made me say,
♪ Baby, I didn't change, I didn't change,
I'm still here,
♪ Let it ride, let it ride, and you'll see,
♪ Come on now, what went wrong?
♪ I told all here, I didn't mean you
no harm or nothing,
♪ Except to set you, my baby, free,
♪ Whatever kept you from leavin' me?
♪ [guitar playing]
♪ She says, "It isn't workin'",
♪ She's had her fill,
♪ Don't have it now,
don't think we ever will,
♪ I don't begrudge you nothing,
♪ I wish you well,
♪ I wish you everything you wish yourself.
♪ Baby, I didn't change, I didn't change,
I'm still here,
♪ Let it ride, let it ride, and you'll see,
♪ Come on now, what went wrong?
I told all here,
♪ I didn't mean you no harm or nothing,
♪ Except to set you, my baby, free,
♪ Whatever kept you from leavin' me?
♪ [guitar playing]
[applause]
Mick Flannery: Thank you.
Mick Flannery: So yes.
This is the most miserable of all pieces
of misery that I've peddled
to people like yourselves.
[guitar strumming]
I'll be checking for who's asleep
after this.
[guitar strumming]
This is called "Near or Far."
♪ [guitar playing]
♪ Man of a moneyed mind,
♪ A trophy wife,
♪ On his arm to boast,
♪ Their love was dashed,
on the diamond coast.
♪ [guitar playing]
♪ Born was a single heir,
To the ideal pair,
To the careless two,
Who choked the child,
On the silver spoon.
♪ [guitar playing]
Now the couple take turns,
Tryin' to out-do each other,
The more riches the better,
The father or the mother.
♪ [guitar playing]
Love at sweet sixteen,
The king and queen,
the wedding bells,
Could well have warned,
what time would tell.
♪ [guitar playing]
The cut above her eye,
She could not hide,
From the little boy,
Who knew it wise,
To not make noise.
♪ [guitar playing]
Now he's gone more often,
And she found ways to forget,
And her little boy's hatred,
Is not showing yet.
♪ [guitar playing]
The wife of a working man,
Pills in hand,
Tears the sleeve,
Love was true but could not concede,
♪ [guitar playing]
And years and years go by,
The things they tried
Would fade and growth,
To not give life would kill them both.
♪ [guitar playing]
Now he goes to houses,
Where kissing is banned,
And she has a daughter,
But she's missing a man.
♪ [guitar playing]
And near or far from human,
all this happens often,
all this happens all the time.
♪ [guitar playing]
[applause]
Mick Flannery: Thank you.
Mick Flannery: What time do you
have to get back?[laughter]
>> [INAUDIBLE]
Mick Flannery: What?
[laughter]
I was thinking about all
the foosball things around here.
You probably do nothing around here,
do you?
That's probably not funny.
Coming from me it's pretty rich, anyway.
Is there any Americans in here?
No?
Yes?
You're not supposed to take
offense to this song, okay?
[laughter]
[guitar strumming]
This is actually is an old Confederate song,
which probably isn't cool either.
But it has rhythm in it;
so I just have to wake up the people
who fell asleep with the last song.
[guitar strumming]
It's historical.
♪ [guitar playing]
♪ I'm a good ol' Rebel,
now that's just what I am.
♪ For this here land of freedom,
♪ I do not care a damn.
♪ I'm glad I fought against it,
♪ I only wish we'd won.
♪ And I don't want no pardon
for anything I've done.
♪ [guitar playing]
Well, I hate the Yankee nation
and everything they do.
I hate the Declaration
of Independence, too,
And I hate that glorious Union
is dripping with our blood,
And I hate that striped banner,
I fought it all I could.
♪ [guitar playing]
♪ 300, 000 Yankees are
sniffing Southern dust.
♪ We got 300,000 before
they conquered us.
♪ They died of Southern fever
and Southern steel and shot.
♪ But I wish there was three
million instead of what we got.
♪ [guitar playing]
♪ But I won't be reconstructing.
♪ I'm bitter now than then.
♪ And for them carpetbaggers,
♪ I do not care a damn.
♪ Man, I'm off to the frontier
as soon as I can go,
♪ And I'll prepare a weapon
and head for Mexico.
♪ [guitar playing]
♪ Cause I'm a good ol' Rebel,
♪ now that's just what I am.
♪ For this here land of freedom,
♪ I do not care a damn.
♪ I'm glad I fought against it,
♪ I only wish we'd won,
♪ And I don't want no pardon
for anything I've done.
♪ [guitar playing]
[applause]
Mick Flannery: Thank you.
Touching.
♪ [guitar playing]
♪ Do you love me,
♪ or are you just extending goodwill?
♪ Do you need me half as bad as you say,
♪ or are you just feeling guilt?
♪ I've been burned before
and I know the score
♪ So you won't hear me complain.
♪ Will I be able to count on you
♪ Or is your love in vain?
♪ Are you so fast that you cannot
see that I must have solitude?
♪ When I am in the darkness,
♪ why do you intrude?
♪ Do you know my world?
♪ Do you know my kind?
♪ Or must I explain?
♪ Will you let me be myself,
♪ Or is your love in vain?
♪ Well I've been to the mountains,
♪ I've been in the wind,
♪ I've been in and out of happiness.
♪ I have dined with kings,
♪ I've been offered wings
♪ And I've never been too impressed.
♪ All right, I'll take a chance,
♪ I will fall in love with you.
♪ If I'm a fool,
♪ you can have the night,
♪ you can have the morning too.
♪ Do you cook and sew,
♪ and the flowers grow,
♪ Do you understand my pain?
♪ Are you willing to risk it all?
♪ Or is your love in vain?
♪ [guitar playing]
♪ Do you cook and sew,
♪ and the flowers grow,
♪ Do you understand my pain?
♪ Are you willing to risk it all?
♪ Or is your love in vain?
[applause]
Mick Flannery: Thank you.
What's the story?
I have one more or something.
[guitar strumming]
Have you eaten?
How long is your lunch break?
What?
I want to work here.
Is anyone quitting?
[laughter]
[tuning guitar]
Oh, shoot.
♪ [guitar playing]
♪ It ain't necessarily so.
♪ The things that your teacher
is liable to teach you,
♪ It ain't necessarily so.
♪ [guitar playing]
♪ Little David was small, but oh my.
♪ He fought big Goliath,
♪ who lay low and dieth.
♪ Little David was small, but oh my.
♪ [guitar playing]
♪ Little Moses, he was found
in a stream.
♪ Little Moses was found in a stream.
♪ He floated on water
'til ole Pharaoh's daughter,
♪ She fished him,
she said, from that stream.
♪ [guitar playing]
♪ But it ain't necessarily so.
♪ It ain't necessarily so.
♪ The things you are liable
to read in the Bible,
♪ It ain't necessarily so.
♪ [guitar playing]
♪ Methuselah lived 900 years,
♪ Methuselah, he lived 900 years
♪ But what good is livin'
when no woman will give in
♪ To no man worth 900 years.
♪ [guitar playing]
♪ It ain't necessarily so.
♪ The things that your teacher
is liable to teach you,
♪ It ain't necessarily so.
[applause]
Mick Flannery: Thanks.
Well, I think I'm going to finish up with this
song and let you be happy people again.
[laughter]
Thank you for coming in and
listening to my bullshit.
Cheers
♪ [guitar playing]
♪ If I go down to the tavern, babe,
I won't come back
♪ [guitar playing]
♪ If I go down to the tavern, babe,
I won't come back
♪ [guitar playing]
♪ I'm tryin' to do better,
♪ tryin' to get myself together.
♪ Pick me up,
you gotta put me back on track.
♪ [guitar playing]
♪ Oh, my bed is made in the gutter
but I won't lie down.
♪ [guitar playing]
♪ My bed is made in the gutter
but I won't lie down.
♪ [guitar playing]
♪ Can't stay here forever,
gotta get myself together.
♪ Take my hand, you gotta turn
my look around.
♪ [guitar playing]
♪ But I'm a man with a hurricane hot
on my heels.
♪ I say anywhere, anywhere away
from here.
♪ There's a weight in me
and it won't let me go.
♪ Wanna shine, shine good as I know.
♪ But I do need you,
♪ ah, who will keep me on the straight
and the narrow road.
♪ 'Cause you know that I go a little
bit off track with the bottle,
♪ But you know I think the more you think,
♪ the less you understand,
♪ And the more I try to get things right,
♪ the less they go as planned.
♪ Oh, man.
♪ And when I go down to the station,
will you come with me?
♪ [guitar playing]
♪ When I go down to the station,
will you come with me?
♪ [guitar playing]
♪ Gonna leave this stormy weather,
♪ gonna get our things together.
♪ Morning train would have us
both set free.
♪ But I'm a man with a hurricane
hot on my heels.
♪ I say anywhere, anywhere
away from here.
♪ But there's a weight in
me and it won't let me go.
♪ Wanna shine, shine good as I know.
♪ But I do need you,
♪ ah,
♪ who will keep me on the straight
and the narrow road.
♪ Cause you know that I go a little
bit off track with the bottle,
♪ But you know I think the more you think,
♪ the less you understand,
♪ And the more I try to get things right,
♪ the less they go as planned.
♪ Oh, man.
♪ [guitar playing]
[applause]
Mick Flannery: Thank you very much.
Cheers.
Have a good day.
[applause]